Dr Joel D wallik Visionary author
scientist considered by many to be the
father of liquid mineral supplementation
born just 2 years before the start of
World War II Joel grew up on a small
Missouri farm raising cattle and caring
for livestock which exposed Joel to the
nutritional needs of animals intrigued
by science at an early age Joel was
compelled to understand the importance
of nutrition and the role it played in
health at age 17 Joel earned his Eagle
Scout award as a natural athlete and
head of the high school wrestling team
Joel was convinced that he could do
anything moreover he was motivated to do
something great his interest in animals
led to his first High School job at the
St Louis Zoo working under the watchful
guidance of Marlon Perkins who was later
known for his Sensational television
show Mutual of Omaha's Wild Kingdom at
age 22 wallik earned a Bachelor's of
Science and agriculture from the
University of Missouri under the
guidance of world famous soil scientist
Professor William albrech Dr albrech is
known as the father of soil fertility
research 2 years later majoring in
animal husbandry wallik obtained his
degree of doctor of veterinary
medicine he later went on to take
positions at Iowa State University
diagnostic laboratory in Ames Iowa and
subsequently joined the St Louis
Zoological Gardens as a Wildlife
veterinarian and
pathologist at 25 his determination to
to help animals led him to Africa where
he worked on operation Rhino and
operation elephant to preserve the White
Rhino and the Majestic African elephant
leading to a position with the natal
fish and game department of the natal
Republic of South Africa he was then
called back to the United States at the
request of Marlon
Perkins at 27 Dr Wallock held a
postdoctoral fellowship in comparative
pathology at the center for the biology
of natural systems at St l Louis
Washington
University while working directly with
Marlon Perkins the St Louis Zoo and
Washington University Dr wallik began
establishing his worldwide reputation as
an animal and Zoo expert thus he was
featured in numerous newspapers and
magazines and invited to Zeus around the
world already a Critic of outdated and
entrenched Animal Care practices Dr
wallik was pushing for changes to
benefit the health and well-being of
animals thus extending their lifespan
at 38 Dr wallik made a landmark
Discovery while working as a research
pathologist for the yeres primate Center
on the basis of observations on reesus
monkeys he proposed that cystic fibrosis
in humans was an acquired and treatable
condition rather than a true congenital
disorder this New Concept startled the
medical and cystic fibrosis
establishment so much that Dr Wall's
professional qualifications were openly
brought into question and he was
unceremoniously fired from his position
at
yery his firing was widely covered by
the media leading to an invitation to
speak along with World leading
scientists at an International Symposium
on Trace elements organized by Dr Gart
shraer Professor
UCSD in his lecture Dr wallet proposed
that cystic fibrosis is an
environmentally induced disease rather
than genetically transmitted as a simple
mandalian autosomal recessive disease
mentioning selenium vitamin e zinc
copper and riboflavin as the factors
associated with biological membrane
protection his lecture was well received
and helped him regain his professional
standing scientific research would later
validate Dr Wall's
hypothesis this Landmark discovery
changed the trajectory of his career and
Dr wallik felt compelled to return to
college and obtain another degree so he
could bring forward his Discovery to the
human species at 43 Dr wallet graduated
from the National College of
naturopathic medicine as a doctor of
naturopathic medicine his third degree
in higher education Dr Wallock then went
on to become a partner in three clinics
actively practicing medicine as a
licensed naturopathic physician in the
state of
Oregon at 43 he published the definitive
work on caring for exotic animals with
diseases of exotic animals a work that
took him 20 years to complete and today
is recommended by the Smithsonian
Institute Dr Dr Wallock would later meet
his current wife Dr malan Who was a
guest Professor specializing in
microsurgery at Harvard University the
two of them would go to China to
continue researching and studying Dr
Wall's cystic fibrosis Discovery as news
of Dr Wall's Discovery theories and
research spread Dr Wall was invited to
lecture around the world at 49 he was
awarded the woster beach gold medal
award for scientific achievement for his
cystic fibrosis Discovery by age 52 he
had published more than 70 peer-reviewed
and referenced Journal articles and two
bestselling books on human nutrition
let's play doctor and rare Earth's
forbidden cures he has since written
numerous books on the subject of
nutrition and wellness at 54 one of Dr
Wall's lectures was recorded and has
become the most widely heard and
distributed nutritional lecture in
history now distributed via CD and print
Dead Doctors Don't Lie has been
duplicated over 105 million times
worldwide at 64 he was awarded the James
Lynn scientific Achievement Award and
the guardian of the Constitution award
for his tireless pursuit of Health
Freedom Dr wallik has continued to
lecture around the globe speaking to
doctor groups professional athletes and
the general public he has been sought
out by athletes and professionals around
the world sharing his wisdom and
knowledge with the National Basketball
Players Association his expertise has
led him to help various professional
athletes such as Theo Ratliff of the Los
Angeles Lake Lakers supporting their
health and extending their careers with
thousands pressing Dr Wallock for his
formula for Optimal Health and Longevity
Dr wallik founded his own company now
known as young jevity in San Diego
California Dr wallik has popularized
liquid supplement technology worldwide
and millions have since benefited from
his advice and research Dr wallik has
been driven to pursue his dream and
passion of educating the world about
nutrition he continues to speak nearly
300 days a year and hosts a daily radio
program as well an American Patriot and
health Freedom Champion Dr Joel wallik